[Music]
we have seen our gripping and sad
interview last week with Horace Lorenzo
Anderson seniors father who told us
about the heartbreaking experience he
lost his 19 year old son and the Summer
of Love chop and Chazz zone now mr.
Anderson has received an outpouring of
support including we're told a phone
call from the president President Trump
and finally a meeting with Seattle's
mayor he returns tonight to give us an
update along with the founder and
executive director of not this time
andre taylor mr. anderson thank you for
being back everybody asked me nobody
called mr. Anderson nobody during this
show as it was going on the White House
switchboard called asking for your
number what has happened since a lot of
things that happened just because of
your show I believe and I I want to just
say first of all I want to give my heart
out to every one man because of your
show people have been reaching out to me
with the man the most man the best you
know that man around the world I've got
cards from around the world people I
don't even know just reaching out to me
saying you're great dad and just
different things I wish I had a dad like
you things like this you know so it's
it's been very over what was the process
and it's about that kind of like just
you know just basic he called and you
know gave his condolences but you know
like I say you know a phone call is like
you know like I call you and tell you I
love you you know I can tell you that
but it's a different thing when
somebody's right there at your door and
embracing you Nick tell you love you can
feel the love you know so I don't you
know I'm not an apology so I don't know
if the conversation was just
conversation or speaking as his father
sounds like well mr. Taylor what about
the mayor it's inexcusable mr. Taylor
well she allowed this to happen she
didn't protect mr. Anderson's son she
should have she should have protected
the city the people of her city I want
to go back to the president's phone call
because we were both on the phone call
the president was was extremely gracious
yeah
he called it a perfect time hearing the
funeral services it just lifted horse up
he was just like elated screaming yeah I
got a call from the president so I don't
want to belittle the power of the
presidency no or the seat of the
presidency it was very very special for
him it was very very special for myself
whatever your politics are that doesn't
matter
the office is the most powerful office
in this world and to be able to receive
a phone call from the president listen
it gets no higher than that yeah and
that's and I just want to say that so we
covered that I've got a lot of reaction
too and everybody that I talked to
everyone's that's written me everybody I
saw over the weekend sends their love
and prayers to you and I send mine too
my heartfelt as a father to father thank
you both for being with us she'll be in
our prayers we'll stay in touch thank
you